This is the [inaudible] new year and new year's Eve.
Uh,
so you talked about succession and the world burning down and
you holding the match at the end. Yes.
They ending with a big smile on your face. Yes. Why so serious,
but, uh,
let me ask you if it doesn't include flame and succession and
destruction and laughing malice in makeup, in a white suit at the end,
uh, how do we bring more kindness and love to the world in 2021,
easy be comfortable saying I want to be
happy.
And if there's someone who interjects and gives you attitude,
arms length them,
surround yourself with people who also want to be happy. Here's a great example.
My buddy, Chris Williamson, who I've mentioned before,
he's a podcast or does modern wisdom if he's, he's an awesome dude.
And we became friends, very close friends this past year.
And he was in Dubai recently and he sent me pictures from Dubai, by the pool,
just loving life.
And it took me a week and then it clicked in my head and I'm like,
you know what? For some other people,
if they saw him under remodel at the pool,
they would think this is him bragging or humbled bragging.
And that never entered my head. I'm like, Oh man,
I'm so glad my boy can be having a good time and is sharing
his joy with me. That's the kind of people you need to surround yourself with,
where it never enters their head to be resentful or anything other than
sharing in your bounty. What makes you happy?
I'm happy all the time. And one of the points I made in my life is like,
I really hate it.
I really did not like to give advice because I feel don't give advice until you
know what you're talking about. And to me,
what makes me happy is being self-actualized.
I am in a position with my career where I could be myself 24
seven,
where I never have to engage in small talk where I never have to interact with
someone I don't want to.
And I'm very blessed to have that very few people have that.
And to have that be not only, um,
to have that be like rewarded and having people find that something of value to
them makes me very, very happy, but also being an uncle, you know,
I have two little nephews there. They make me very, very happy.
I'm sure my sister's raising him Russian. So they talk like immigrants,
but that's okay. We're going to change that. Um, we have to dismember her.
That's fine. That makes me happy. And like, uh, to be able to,
to be able to finish this book and know it's going to give people a sense of
hope. That's really validating. Wow.
What are you most grateful for for our conversation?
You're stealing my bet. What am I most grateful for?
I am very grateful that I can come in here,
not knowing what we're going to talk about and know it's not going to
be something I have to be on guard about,
or I have to watch my words and that neither you or your audience is going
to be, uh, responding derisively.
I feel safe here. You're welcome. But Steven,
thanks for talking to me. This is awesome.